yo welcome to this video ah super puma
super puma okay the duck okay probably
we get a stone wall jack oh just
checking right into the right into me
weird alright a bit weird to have this
Jack played without see for being played
really that's really weird I g'nite be
three what is he playing d5 and I'll be
three sm also strange-looking move just
a three I mean this is just just weird
well maybe if I go here night see for
this is not leading to much but I can
maybe just push in an 94
Jeff not sure the many moves look
attractive this whole position is just
just very strange but I'm not sure at
all what blacks blacks ideas here
whatwhat setup is here is the aiming for
um I can take here take b6 maybe this
one I'm not clear it all looks quite
nice okay I don't mind why not taking
with this it's just just a great
position for wide a5 b5 and tes not even
developed the c8 bishop or anything
next plan could be simply a five and be
five advancing um yeah okay just grab
the space okay so um what next what next
would like to exchange the bishop as an
idea of course I mean stabilize matters
a bit I can at the moment I cannot play
92 we will exchange and clay rook takes
a five which I probably don't don't want
maybe 91 also move but a diff 95 that's
also f8 hanging okay yeah that's a very
nice position but you will feel tempted
to spend lots of time to really refute
it completely and maybe there is no
complete reputation I don't know I i yes
g5 okay i was thinking f3 but 95 is
still an ok response yeah be six cents
also no Knight b6 he will take him i'll
probably be six there's some pressure on
d6 now f3 is really really a threat yeah
okay i'm going to take t6
that is all very hard to believe now I
think I can just take a take d 6 i'm not
sure Bishop takes on knight takes Bishop
takes probably Bishop takes Bishop your
night takes we should be six unless
specially six
96 that's not even so clear should be 60
k doing something else in this is also
quite nice putting the night only five
year there should be six I can just take
okay it's got Queen D for crap it's got
queen dee for time morning now that was
just unlucky i overlooked a queen dee
for I thought I can just take and he's
got this is silly Queen D for resource
I'm not sure that this was so good no no
def 7s threaten the threatening with the
smothered mate
check I thought I can take 96 but he's
got just kingi and no this is not so
great check i can do that King g8 I can
take on d5 this isn't made even with
fatigue with the Queen Jack and it was
very lucky check black resign so that
was funny at the end but this was a very
lucky win I mean he played the opening
absolutely unbelievably bad but I didn't
refute it I mean around here blackest
black is basically busted but what I
what I played that I was really badly
after that c6 and f3 I don't know b6 be
6 i'll just f3 immediately yeah f3 here
and then unlight c5 you have this day I
have overlooked this resource this is
this is winning her white b7 hangs I
mean the whole position is a disaster
I've got those two nights and I'm very
active this is plus 3 point something
but my problem was I was I was relying
on the fact that I have Quinn take c 6
in this position this was my my idea Jay
wins but I I had overlooked that after
greene takes shy of course he can give
this check and this this is downright
losing so I was relying on this tactic
but it simply was not working
or 95 is just fantastic a wide and hear
ya hear black is just winning simply as
simple as that can enter there are many
things when here look take see five is
one way that the computer is suggesting
with a decisive a check for black minus
five they are not a surprise this is
still winning Jack but this is so this
is a blunder actually I went yeah and
here he can actually take Jack and play
this position where black is winning now
he's got this week b6 pawn and my king
is in danger as well so black wins here
instead of night g6 this was actually
leading to a draw which is funny here
and then just move like interesting the
reason is that this is in fact check a
perpetual check hmm okay you know jack
this is this is a key point Paula
perpetual okay so night g6 was a mistake
it led to win because he blundered into
this which is which is giving me this
check check make this very attractive
made at the end very very lucky I
overlooked this Queen d4 otherwise i
think it was okay there were many
alternatives probably but it was pretty
convincing refutation up to the point
where i overlooked it should be six move
okay thanks for watching